Hey! Welcome back everybody
to the next episode of FP101x.
And today we're going to talk about
recursive functions.
What is recursion? Well, I have here
a stack of trays and my favorite fruit.
By now you all know that I love bananas.
And I need to eat this
whole bunch of bananas. And if we're
going to do this recursively, so I'm
going to eat the first banana and then...
oh but
before I do that, I need to eat the next
banana.
Oh, so I have to put this one
on top of this tray and then...
Oh, I have to eat
the next banana. My goodness, I'm eating a
lot of bananas. And look at that stack
growing there. Next banana
and finally I have my last banana
and I can put it on the stack. And look
it is a beautiful stack
of bananas. See if we can
see them. The problem is that what we
have done here
is we have created a quite a large
stack of bananas. And if we would have a
big bunch of bananas that stack
would overflow. So a better way
to eat the bananas is to not
start with the next banana until you've
finished
the first one. And in that case
you only need one tray
to finish all your bananas.
And that is called tail call elimination.
And tail call elimination is
a very important concept when you're
using recursion
to define control structures. And in
imperative languages
typically you don't have tail call
elimination
and therefore you have specialized
control structures. But in Haskell
we can define
we can
safely define our control structures
using recursive functions
because we will never have this giant
stack
of uneaten bananas. Great, let's look at
some code.
I think I have had enough
bananas for the rest of the year.
The reason Haskell
folks love recursion is that it's
often a very natural way
to define functions. For example
here is a way to define
the factorial function.
We have seen this one before, so
we take the list
of values between 1 to n and then
we multiply them all together.
If we are going to evaluate
this factorial 4, we unfold
the definition. That was
product 1 to 4. The list 1 to 4
is the product 1,2,3,4
and the product was
just multiplying all the numbers.
So there you see the product of 1,2,3,4
is 1 x 2 x 3 x 4
which is 24.
Here is a way to define
factorial using recursion. And we
have seen
how to define recursive functions
over lists
by taking the list, checking whether
it is the
empty list or whether it is the head
followed by the tail.
And in some sense this kind of recursive
function
over numbers is nothing different.
So we have two cases. We have the fact
whether the number is 0
or in this case whether the number is n
and in that case the recursion will be
on n-1.
In a previous version of Haskell there
were so-called
n+k patterns, where you could
write the factorial of 0
and the factorial of n+1, but
n+k patterns have been
deprecated, so now you
will have to write it in this form.
But apart from that minor detail, what you
can see is that it is
very very similar to the way
you define recursion over lists.
There are two cases: 0
and n, and if it is 0 it's 1,
and otherwise
you just take the factorial of
(n-1) times n.
And if we evaluate
this form of factorial, you will see
that stack
of bananas appearing, because
you see that
there's the factorial going to the
right
until we have executed everything
and then we multiply going back
popping off the stack, to get back to 6.
Alright.
The recursive definition
that we have given, of course will
not terminate, or a fancy way to say
that, is it will diverge
for numbers less than 0.
If we look here. Let's go back
a few slides. If n
is less than 0, then
this case doesn't apply, so we
multiply n with the factorial
of (n-1)
which is even more less than zero, and
so on, and so on. So this will never
terminate
and it will cause a stack overflow.
Some functions like factorial can be
defined
either recursively or defined in terms
of other functions.
Whether you define something using
recursion
or in terms of other functions, or you
take this recursion pattern
and abstract it as a higher-order
function and
then use it to define the function, that's
all a matter of taste.
In the end you decide as a developer
what is the most readable
for other developers. Alright?
So there is no strong answer when
or not to use recursion.
The code just has to be as clear as
possible.
But one advantage of recursion is that
you can use
induction to prove properties
of your function. Let's
look at another example of defining a
recursive function
where we are using this product
function, that we
used in the earlier definition
of factorial, and let's define that
using recursion over lists. So in this
case the structure is exactly the same.
There are
two cases. We either have the empty list
or we have a list of n cons ns.
We look at the recursive structure
of lists
and then we define the function over
that recursive structure.
And the same with numbers: we look at the
recursive structure of numbers
and then we define the functions
according to that structure.
In this case: if we have the product of
the empty list
well, that is 1. If we want to
take the product of a value n on top of
a list ns
what do we do? We take the product
of the rest of the list here and then we
multiply that by n.
So this is a very easy way
to define this function using recursion.
And of course
as we will see, we can take this
function and
abstract the pattern into a higher-order
function, that just does the recursion
and then we can plug in
the times and the 1. But if we
execute this product, we unfold the
definition.
So it's like 2 cons 3,4.
If we unfold that a couple of times
you get 2
times the product of 3,4. We do that a
couple of times
until we arrive here. And then
we pop the stack to get 24. Alright?
So you see that the answer is exactly
the same
as the recursive definition of
factorial.
The only thing is that in this case the
recursion
is hidden in this product function.
So if we take the product
of the numbers 1 to n, really we're
defining
the function using recursion as well.
And you can show that
when you fuse these two functions, the
function that creates a list from 1 to n
and the product function, that what you
get is effectively
the recursive definition of factorial.
Let's look at another function, that we can
define
recursively over lists.
And here you see again: we have this
recursive structure, so if the
list is empty
the length of that empty list is 0 and
if the list is not empty, we don't care really
what the first element is. We compute
the length of the rest of the list
and just add 1 to it. Super obvious.
Again, it follows the recursive structure
of the list. So it is kind of defined by
induction
on the structure of the list.
So length of 1,2,3
1 + length of 2,3, unfold, unfold,
unfold
until here and then we add them up
and we get the answer that we expect:
three. Here is another function:
reverse. Empty list.
Reverse of the empty list is empty list.
And if we want to reverse x:xs
we just add x on the other side.
If we execute it like this, you see
that we are appending the elements
from right to left
and then the list gets reversed.
So 1,2,3 turns into 3,2,1.
Of course
we can also define recursive functions
that
don't recurse over just one argument,
but over several.
We have seen in the previous chapter the
function zip.
How do we define zip? Zip took two lists
and it would take every element of the
two lists and combine them into a pair.
The easiest thing here is to look at the
last
clause here. If we have two non-empty
lists
we take the head of both, put that in a
pair
and recursively zip the rest.
When do we stop? Well, we stop
when either of the two lists is
exhausted
in which case we return the empty list.
And of course we have to put
these cases first here, because there is
a wildcard
pattern here, that would otherwise not
work.
Good!
A few more functions.
Drop takes an integer and a list
and returns a list. And what this thing
is doing, it's recursing over
both
the integer and the list. So in this case
when we say we want to drop zero
elements from a list
well, that's the same list. If we have
the empty list
we can drop whatever we want, but
we won't get
very far, so we just return the empty
list. And otherwise
we recurse both over the list and over
the number.
And again, since we don't have n+k
patterns, we have to use n-1 here
on the right hand side, so drop of n
and whatever cons xs is drop of
(n-1) and xs. So here we
recurse
over the structure of the number and the
structure
of the list.
The last example here on the slide
appends two lists. If I want to
append the empty list to another list,
that is the other list.
And then, if I want to append a
list x:xs
to a list ys, I first append xs to ys
and then cons x on top. Super
obvious.
Thank you so much and see you
in part 2.